I mean it looks totally doable looks and
smells delicious
we'll take a Dorito three two one
Yolo spicy okay just like a Dorito
honestly it's spicy but it's not that
bad not the hottest thing that I've ever
had I don't think I think I'm Terry whoa
yeah I'm tearing up oh my god
okay wait my god
my tongue is numb okay it's starting to
hurt now all men I might use there's
like a pain cemented in all of my mouth
okay
hello ever might taking that back I am
tearing up literally right that is right
I touched my eye when I was not supposed
to I'm not feeling all that great
where's the pain everywhere oh my god I
have no idea why I signed up for this I
didn't describe that pain like there's
gasoline on fire and in my mouth it
feels like someone's someone stabbing me
inside of my mouth it's like getting a
bunch of paper cuts on your donnas why
why would anyone even yeah maybe it is
bad I can't feel my lips right now but
huh well is it you start questioning
everything it's hurt so much that my
tongue doesn't work the way it's
supposed to so scale of one to ten how
would you rank this thousand this is
definitely the spiciest thing I've ever
had but it's not an enjoyable spicy
thing I had everyone
oh yeah it's coming back that's the
cross think about it like you think it's
over and then it's just oh no what the
garbage can
I'm not glad like at all I hate my life
[Music]
we did we need to see an email and go
yeah